chebbi vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
fassions une interview alerte aux roses
en embauchent pendant ledit guerre
on ne bouge pas pendant les juniors
moi bien est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour de faire
l'amour pourrait mais ni l'un ni l'autre
vous êtes 23 lors d'un fantasme quel est
pour vous le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte la rue la russie des trottoirs
c'est un bordel un porche non la rue est
ce que vous préférez un homme qui dès ce
bien mais qui est infidèle ou un homme
qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
moi je pense que je préfère un mec qui
bosse bien et qui est fidèle en
apparence jamais mais des mecs qui
bettman qui sont infidèles aussi est ce
que vous préférez être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aime
au fond j'ai dit que j'étais une baleine
échouée kivu rennes grappin sur moi mais
est ce que vous préférez que votre mec
fasse l'amour avec une autre en pensant
à vous ou fast allemand avec vous en
pensant à une autre
compensant une autre ouais ouais c'est
plus sympa clementé rien aucun sens rien
sens que ça arrive ça c'est comme ça ça
peut arriver
j'ai pas de mire
j'ai pas de max est ce que vous préférez
faire l'amour avec 1000 mec toujours de
la même façon
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes 3000 mec alors là on s'y
attendait c'est important a cédé
question du mec mais jérémy le mec
toujours la même façon plutôt qu'un mec
de mille façons à faire en mi mai qu un
remake art group of here l'arrivée après
robert
c'est plus sympa et vous ai manqué au
nom de la médiation et bien sûr moi ça
me rendrait ce que vous dites là parce
que moi après j'ai mes emails toutes les
classes
je pense qu'on soit champion
si on pouvait
mais ce secret
tél